hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the subject of the very first chapter of
franz fanon's book
black skin white masks is language
we can think of it as a dimension of
human existence an
aspect of the colonial dynamic
it reveals a number of things with with
an
analysis that fanon wants to
be able to put out there and you know
it's interesting he's doing this in
language he's doing this in the french
language so there's already an aspect
of you could say reflexivity
to the very critical analysis that he's
engaging in
here so why language well
fanon brings up a number of points that
are kind of
common in 20th century
philosophy and more broadly speaking in
the understanding of language
in culture so he tells us at the very
beginning
that it's implicit that to speak
is to exist absolutely
for the other and he says i ascribe a
basic importance to the phenomenon of
language that's why i find it necessary
to begin with this
this should provide us with one of the
elements in the colored man's
comprehension
of the dimension of the other the other
so you know is are we talking about the
white other here are we talking about
the
other black other are we talking about
the other who is oneself
in alienation well all of these
language is complex and as we open it up
we get to see
what is involved in this existing
for the other human beings are
linguistic beings we exist
through language and and because of
language
through a culture or cultures
generally that we share and also contest
with each other so this is a very
important point and he goes on and says
the black man has two dimensions one
with his fellows the other with the
white man
a negro behaves differently with a white
man and with another
negro that this self-division is a
direct result of colonial
colonialist subjugation is beyond
question and so that's that's an
important
connection language is not just going to
be something that we all
share it's going to be a sphere in which
this bifurcation takes place and
alienation
from from oneself and actually since
fanon is using psychoanalytic categories
here a kind of
neurosis that gets developed
so language as he's going to go on
says it involves an orientation
towards more than just
just uh you know speaking and he says to
speak means to be in a position to use a
certain
syntax to grasp the morphology of this
or that language like we're speaking
english right now and you can understand
what i'm saying
if this is a second language for you you
probably had to study
aspects of english like you know how
our weird spelling system was is
entirely
crazy only the french probably have a
spelling system
as goofy as ours you know
how we conjugate verbs all of that sort
of stuff
there are certain skills that you
develop with learning a language but
learning a language is
way way more than just mastering the
elements of grammar or
even you might say the pragmatics of
human communication
he says it means above all to assume
a culture to support the weight of
a civilization now obviously not every
use of language does that you know if
you're
learning something so that you can just
communicate with people in a business
context and then go home and you know
take your tie and shirt off and
sit there and watch whatever you're
going to watch in your own language it's
not quite the same thing
he's talking about taking on a language
though as something that opens up
a mode of access to us a little bit
later on this is actually
not a passage i was going to bring up
but it's really apropos
he tells us that there is a
psychological phenomenon that consists
in the belief that the world will
open to the extent to which frontiers
are broken down so the promise in
learning
somebody else's language particularly
when that's something that
isolates you and their culture is
in a certain way opposed to your own but
also exploiting it and telling you that
your culture is inferior
learning the language seems like it
should open up a number of doors and
allow one to shift out of that
situation learning a language involves
some sort of orientation to an entire
culture or civilization a little bit
later on he says
to speak a language is to take on a
world
a culture so this is a
very important idea we're going to see
this passage
come up again so shifting languages
shifting dialect is how he talks about
it here
means shifting one's thinking
he says what is the origin of this
personality change that we're going to
look at in a bit what is the source of
this new way of being
every dialect is a way of thinking
damaret and pinchon
said to through linguists right and the
fact that the newly returned negro
adopts a language different from that of
the group into which he was born
is evidence of a dislocation a
separation when we change the way in
which we're speaking to people
and you know we can note this in all
sorts of phenomena all over the world
we change the way that people look at us
and we change
also the way that we look at ourselves
you know
when i speak and people you know comment
on my wisconsin accent which can
sometimes be a little bit thick
at times they're saying something about
not just the way i talk but
you know where i come from
i remember when i was learning mandarin
and i was doing so with taiwanese
students
that there was a certain sort of tough
guy dialect
that the guys would take on
in the way that they would pronounce
certain uh monosyllabic
words that the women wouldn't do and
actually kind of look
down on you know those are dialects
these these
are are quite important so shifting our
language shifting the dialect that we're
in
changes uh our ways of thinking
and our ways of being or what we're
perceived
as being not just for ourselves but also
for
others so the problematic that he's
going to
be attacking here is the interrelation
between the languages
of colonized people and the languages
of the colonizers and
now to just to you know point this out
when we're talking about these phenomena
like language
it's not as if somebody who belongs to
say colonial france
at one point in time said you know i
want to oppress the colonized
people i'm going to definitely study my
french so that that can be a tool of
oppression he's not saying anything like
that he's talking about much
you know wider and in many cases
unconscious
dynamics so going back to
to the very beginning of this
he he's talking about the language
that that is being used
and he says that um
here we go every colonized people in
other words
every people in whose soul and
inferiority complex has been created
by the death and burial of its local
cultural
originality finds itself face to face
with the language of the civilizing
nation that is with the culture
of the mother country the colonized is
elevated above his jungle status in
proportion to his adoption of the mother
country's cultural standards
he becomes whiter this is the dynamic
we're going to look at as he renounces
his blackness his jungle
and we'll talk about how that happens in
a moment but first we should think about
this implication
this is a important point about fanon's
analysis
so he's he's not saying that this is
just black and white
every colonized people every people and
whose soul and inferiority complex
has been created by the death and burial
of its local cultural originality
but finds itself face to face with the
language of the civilizing
nation so this this could in theory be
applied to
empires and colonizers all over the
world
throughout history and perhaps if things
don't change
to similar situations even going
on today or into the future
hundreds of years from now so we could
think about
not just you know french european french
and black africa and the antilles
and and other places as well we might
also think about french indochina too
in in that comparison where now it's not
a matter of blackness but rather
uh a different you know ethnicity and
set of ethnicities
involved but we could also think about
america
and english with with them or the
english empire or
the belgians and their their you know
imposition of
a terrorizing and genocidal
regime in africa also using the french
language
or we could think about
the displacement of so many other
languages
by russian or you know
uh arabic or spanish or
hindi or pick whatever we want we think
about the han chinese and
and the current state of ethnic
minorities
in communist china so this is a very
wide analysis now to come back to what
what he's talking about
there is this phenomenon of what we can
call
double language use there is what he
calls dialect or he also picks out
creole
and pidgin versus having something
like an accent so what's going on here
you know when somebody is speaking
french they can speak with a variety of
accents as a matter of fact
my family is french canadian on my
mother's side
and my mother actually even though she
was you know fourth generation american
she grew up speaking french canadian in
chicago
in a certain district and when she went
to france in paris because of her thick
accent she got called a peasant people
made fun of her
for her french canadian accent so it's
quite possible to be you know singled
out
regardless of you know racial lines
as he goes on and he says there is the
city there is the country there is the
capital there is the province
apparently the problem in the mother
country is the same
let us take a leone second largest city
in in
france in paris he boasts of the quiet
of his city
the intoxicating beauty of the caves of
the roan the splendor of the plane trees
and all those other things that
fascinate people who have nothing to do
if you meet him again
when he's returned from paris and
especially you don't know the capital he
will never run out of its
praises paris city of light there's an
inferiority complex
in relation to the capital so it's not
just black and white
it's also different whites within
france right and it could be leon
by comparison to some country town over
you know in in the west or something
like that as well there's lots and lots
of layers of stratification
based on how we talk based on what we
talk about we can have
the same accent but talk about
stuff that people think is lower class
or not that
important right so um
going on a little bit further than this
he says
the process repeats itself with the man
of martinique
first of all on his island boss plant
marigold
gross mourn and opposite the imposing
fort
france and this is the important point
beyond his island
right so people can pile up these these
ways of talking on top of each other
in hierarchies now he does point out
something really quite important though
that does have to do with with race
there's a little bit further into the
chapter
he says i meet a russian or a german who
speaks french badly that is they speak
with you know sort of russianized or
germanized
grammar right and they also
speak with an accent with gestures i try
to give him the information he requests
at the same time i can hardly forget he
has a language of his own
a country and that perhaps he is a
lawyer engineer there
in any case he is foreign to my group
his standards must be different
when it comes to the case of the negro
nothing of the kind
he has no culture no civilization no
long historical past
this may be the reason for the strivings
of contemporary negroes to prove the
existence of a black civilization to the
white world
at all costs now this you know we can
say
that there's been more development in
this way and
that you know if we think about hegel's
view on africa as a
prime example of this that he has no
history we know that that's nonsense
that's garbage
but fanon's point is yeah yeah that's
all true
we can talk about all these you know
pre-european colonial
uh situations and civilizations but
until there's recognition
that these different ways of speaking
are
rooted in something that isn't just of
the jungle just of
you know a barbarism it's not going to
matter
and so that's the situation that he's
writing from
at the time speaking in creole or
pigeon or any sort of black dialects
is going to be frowned upon and there's
a dilemma that's posed
for people who grow up say you know as
he does
in the antilles or in other places that
have been colonized
do you speak french or do you speak your
dialect
you become bilingual in a certain sense
within a language
family and then which do you use this is
the phenomenon that we nowadays call
code switching right
where people know how to speak in
different
ways to different sets of people
and there is a dilemma that is being
posed
one of identifying oneself with the
universal
which is going to be french and not just
french but french french parisian french
or identifying oneself with where you
actually come from your your culture
which has been
you know essentially colonized and
francified you could say
and so he he discusses this at a couple
of different
points he tells us that when students
from the antilles
meet in paris they have these these two
choices they can stand with the white
world
speak french and then be you know
inclining towards a certain degree of
universality
or they can reject europe speak in their
own dialect with each
other making themselves comfortable in
the
umvelt or environment of martinique and
in that case they're not going to be
taken as seriously if they're
approaching universal questions
and not just by the white students or
fellow professors or
intellectuals but by each other
this dilemma is imposed because of the
prestige associated
with proper french as as it was called
when
i was a kid right so he
says the surest way of cutting him down
is to remind him of the antilles by
exploding into dialect
this must be recognized one of the
reasons why so many friendships collapse
after a few
months of life in europe and he talks
here about alienation
a little bit earlier he also brings up
this this phenomenon
and he says that here we go
what do we do with with somebody who
arrives
in france what do we do with somebody
who comes back from france they're
opposed
with these these issues these dilemmas
speak french
or lapse into dialect every every choice
comes with a set of commitments and
consequences
he also talks about this interesting
phenomenon and it's not just on the part
of whites
because he talks about himself choosing
not to do it as a doctor
and not just in relation to blacks but
also to arabs a major part of the french
cultural sphere right
speaking down to others meaning using
no you know not according them proper
french
but speaking to them in a kind of pigeon
or
dialect so as to you know relate to them
better and he talks about a number of
different reasons and situations in
which
people will will do this um
he talks about you know for example
running into people in bars
or people who've been you know colonials
he talks about
um you know this this priest and
why would a person do this it's a way of
infantilizing
the other person and you might do it in
a sort of paternalistic way you're like
well
this is good for them this way i can
relate to them
better but he you know he points out and
he says
i've observed this behavior in
physicians policemen employers
you know the subject of our study is the
dupes and those who duped them the
alienated and if there are white men who
behave naturally when they meet negroes
they certainly don't fall within the
scope of our examination
you know i'm talking about people who do
in fact talk to
negroes this way he says it gets down to
their level it puts them at ease it's an
effort to understand them and he says
well no this this really
isn't the case and he says
it makes people angry why because they
are not
just pigeon speakers they are capable
of speaking in other ways and fanon
contrasts this
to a couple different cases where he
does this
examining a 73 year old farm woman who
has now gone into
dementia and he uses a uh
you know way of talking to her that's
that's suitable to that he says i talked
down to this poor woman
i condescend to her in my quest for a
diagnosis this is a stigma
of a dereliction in my relations with
other people i shouldn't be doing that
and when i talk i make it a point always
to talk to the
the arabs in normal french and i've
always been
understood rather than talking down to
them so this is
this is a choice right and a lot of
people
demand that patois or that creole or
that pigeon or that dialect
uh in order to be be real or authentic
or something like that
fanon is actually rejecting that he's
saying no no that's not an innocent
choice
he also talks about how things are even
more complex
well maybe they're not more complex they
they're complex in their own way
for those who are from the antilles
he talks about how french is used in
education
and you know in households from the
middle class
up um he's talking about people writing
in dialect he says nothing of the sort
in the antilles the language spoken
officially
is french teachers keep a close watch
over the children to make sure
they do not use creole let us not
mention the ostensible
reasons it would seem the problem in
this in the antilles as
in brittany going back to this point
about you know people speaking dialects
there is a dialect and there is the
french language but this is false
why the bretons don't consider
themselves inferior to the french people
they have never been civilized by the
white man
were the bretons that were talking about
they speak a celtic derived dialect and
they're up in the
northwest of france and they've you know
existed as kind of a separate people
for a long time and ethnos
he's contrasting that there isn't an
inferiority complex
as there is in martinique in the other
parts of the antilles
so they insist on using french in
education
don't speak creole that's that's for the
lower class people as a matter of fact
that will eventually die out hopefully
they think and he talks about the
mastery of french
opening at least in theory not in
practice however
certain doors he says very early on
the problem we will confront in this
chapter is this the negro
of the antilles will be proportionally
whiter
that is he will come closer to being a
real human being indirect ratio to his
mastery of the french
language i'm not unaware that this is
one of man's attitudes face to face to
being
a man who has a language consequently
possesses the world expressed
and implied by that language so
by having french the antillean
is able to overcome at least in theory
not
actually in practice however this racial
dynamic able to treat him or herself
as having a higher status and he
actually does
talk um here we go and paid
a little bit later on he says
to speak a language is to take on a
world of culture the antilles negro who
wants to be white will be the wider as
he gains greater mastery of the cultural
tool
that language is now
how is this going to work it works
within
the antillean situation and you might
say within
the colonized black world it also works
to a certain extent in france so long as
certain conditions hold in the mother
country you could say
all right um and he talks here about the
privileged position of the antilleans he
talks about them
as he says ruling the black roost
and again we have linguistic examples
here
he says i've known people born in
dahomey or the congo who pretend to be
natives of the antilles i've known and
still know
antilles negros when they are suspected
of being senegalese
why why what's going on there why why
care about that background
because there is a hierarchy
the antilles negro is viewed as more
civilized than the african
closer to the white man in this
difference prevails not only in back
streets and on boulevards but also in
public service
and the army he talks about you know the
relation between the senegalese and
and antillians in the military
he talks about people trying to pass as
belonging to the antilles by birth or
things like that
and ridicules some of this
he goes on and he brings this up again
later on a senegalese learns creole
right the viewed as an inferior language
in the antilles in order to pass as an
antilles native
i call this he says alienation the
senegalese
is alienating him or herself from
themselves from their background in
senegal to try to take on a new
ethnicity essentially
by learning creole and then he goes on
he says the antilles negros who know him
never weary of making jokes about him
i call this a lack of judgment they
don't realize that they're
also caught up within this this
linguistic dynamic
as as well and we can come back to this
focus on the mastery of french language
he thinks that the antillean situation
is in many respects different
than that of um other
you could say members of this this
entire
colonized sphere and in particular other
black
writers he he goes on and he says that
the in the antilles here we go
historically it must be understood the
negro wants to speak french because it's
the key that can open doors which were
still barred to him 50 years ago
in the antilles negros situation who
comes within the study we find a quest
for subtleties for refinements of
language
so many further means of proving to
himself he's measured
up to the culture so there isn't this
let's return to creole
instead it's let's make our french the
best french it can possibly be
so that we can gain access to what
french
culture uh provides to us and
we'll close here with with this
discussion he has of jean paul sartre
who's you know uh says an orfeh noir
which prefaces the ontology to the
nouvelle
tells us that the black poet will turn
against the french language
interestingly what does fanon say says
that does not apply to the
antillean that may apply to others but
that's not going to apply to
in the antilles why because
in the antilles french is
you know you could say that's what
they've they've decided upon
it's the sign of superiority
of you know the possibility of opening
these doors but it's also the index
of a continuing alienation due to racism
due to colonialism
due to all of these other factors that
he is describing in the book
which induce this
uh psychodynamic that he's
that he's engaged in analyzing
you